let me let me compliment you I hear a
lot of laughs in this business and you
are not you and I have known each other
quite a while I think you have one of
the most recognizable laughs if anyone I
know is that true yes children will know
you by your laugh that's true
I've been shushed by children really
that's true I've been in restaurants and
little boys and girls they've been like
keep it down try to eat over here
ridiculous I like laughing I'm a
comedian
yeah comedians are supposed to be jaded
cynical angry bitter people but I'm not
I'm a silly silly fun boy yeah you enjoy
you you always seem that way to me you
know life is temporary where we die one
day
live it up people are too hard on jokes
[Applause]
someone who tells a joke people are like
scanning scanning for relevance delivery
haha just laugh we die
laugh I like being an easy life but
people make I can even out of my
monologue every night when I come out
laughs we die laugh
it's gonna work for me that way but I
see what you're saying you know I mean
easy laughs as anybody else an easy
laughs I won't make funny yeah here's
the thing
Andy's a tough laugh by the way he just
isn't it's so funny that kinda for 23
years he's been sitting out here next to
me and I'm doing stuff and he's like
it's called keeping it real it's true
that's the Piney aroma yeah well people
that are hard laughs tend to think
they're better than us easy laughs oh
yeah mock me yeah hey take it easy why
are all your thugs from Boston by the
way with the two buddy f-bombs yeah
exactly look at that lousy idiot over
there laughing at everything
making his joy noise enjoying life like
a real maroon people think it's a good
thing to be a hard life they brag about
it oh yeah I saw a movie and I laughed
and it's hard it's hard to get the
combination to my heart there's barbed
wire and armed guards around the car
yeah work on that yeah that's not good
what do you know Scott - yeah let some
sunlight onto your soul well do you have
suggestions on how people can laugh say
in stressful situations just how can
they find their laugh you know just be
okay with what makes you laugh green
light your own sense of humor and just
dive in you know I mean like I make
myself laugh all the time I'll give it
this is a real example not phony baloney
showbiz this is real if I'm ever in a
plane that's delayed on the tarmac stuck
in traffic I can make myself laugh just
remembering that Lenny Kravitz his name
is Leonard crap
you'll you just remember that that's it
yeah
there's no twister turns you guys are
waiting for more there is no more Lenny
Kravitz the coolest man in the world
cool when he picks up a package he goes
Kravitz Leonard it's a nerd name can
have the word nerd in it Linda don't let
the red pants and the sweet solos fool
you that is a dork name yeah so you give
yourself a little chuckle in that
situation what I'm saying just a weird
guy in 13b like Leonard though like I
saw that movie straight out of Compton
this one works if Lenny if Leonard
Kravitz doesn't get you there when you
need some joy this one might help you
what I like to remember what I learned
in that movie was whenever you're in a
sound booth if you're wearing the
headphones a rapper is in the sound
booth he's the only one that can hear
the music that makes sense so he can
hear it and he's got the mic that means
that if you were in a recording studio
in the 90s with Snoop Dogg this could
have happened you could have been in the
booth with him if you were there with
him this is why you would have seen it
we've just been like
[Laughter]
lalala that's a big he was a cool man
waiting to go when do I go la la la la
la yeah that happened I challenge the
internet to put the music from that song
to me being quiet it'll sync up it'll
sync up exactly I play it in my head
every time I tell that joke Conan okay
cuz I'm not effing around okay
you